[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm rhett and i'm
link this week at the round table of
dimmed lighting
i'm gonna bring you into the world of my
trip back to north carolina three weeks
as i said is a long time to be anywhere
but hey when you haven't seen your
family
since
thanksgiving of 2019
there's lots of stored up energy
and and love to give so you got to go
back home and you got to make sure you
know there's all these conversations are
we gonna we gotta have enough time and
there's no holiday there's no so it's
not like we well there is a july 4th but
there's no like
gift-giving holiday you can get guests
on just christmas tradition type stuff
the gift of freedom the logistics of
holidays tends to
over impose on just a simple
enjoying life with relatives that was
the thesis
going into
our trip i think in in practice
uh there was some business to take care
of um logistically and emotionally
actually back home some of which i
anticipated some of which i didn't and
um
some of which i'm still processing and
of course i save all of my deepest
introspection for this venue rhett right
now if this is your first episode of
beer biscuits welcome ah we never do
this i'm honored that this is this is
the first one you're dipping your toe
into and uh when we do things
in life like go on trips we then do
episodes about them right two life-long
friends talk about life for a long time
last week i talked about my trip to
north carolina which was i loved it
action-packed fun
there was a fire there was white water
rafting zip lining goth a lot of people
have been getting on me lately about the
way they take off
people are like well i don't golf i grew
up in bowie's creek
you say it golf yeah we don't say the l
i guess i say it without it it's just
it's it's not it's a it's a dialect it's
the way that we talk golf yeah i could
say golf golf golf
golf golf but it's unnecessary but i say
golf but i do pronounce the h in white
white uh
so yeah so
today's episode is link sharing his trip
now
so if any i saw you speaking of your
trip
this serendipity would have it that
we were on the same flight back home so
what
why didn't you say anything
it
was
i mean with the masks and all it's hard
to recognize you
i remember having a conversation with
you at the airport so hopefully you do
remember yeah so after our trip yeah we
can we convened and then just happened
to be on the same flight back really i
mean so close to each other that we were
able to like put shepherd and lando and
seats next to each other
you know
um and it was interesting because i
could just see it on your face
yeah what
well first of all i think we were all
ready i mean regardless of how a trip
has gone
at this point in my life i'm always
ready to go back home
i started thinking about the routine and
i started thinking about the and i'm not
even a routine oriented
sort of predictability oriented guy but
yet i still miss a lot of the
conveniences and things that i've kind
of mapped out
and i'm not even on that end of the
spectrum
i am and you had had one week on blowing
the end of the spectrum you had one
additional week on me
and also
based on what you have hinted at without
telling me you it seems that you had
there was uh there was heavier things
going on i have said that haven't i um
but i mean it and coming back home
especially especially after
you know being isolated in your home and
you know i i like my home and i like the
people in my home and we found a way to
make it work and optimize things and i
like to optimize things
but even beyond that when you got these
two precious dogs that you have is
chrissy is like is jasper going to
remember me she she would always say
that i mean yes he's going to remember
you you have a lot of faith in your dogs
of course they remembered us and saka
the cat even seemed a little happy
to have us back
but the dogs were ecstatic you know
uh we walk in the door
and they're like making fools in them
happy peeing on the floor it's like i
mean i would love to get so happy that i
just
pee on the floor i mean pull my pants
down and then pee on the floor just
not just pee in my pant i wouldn't pee
on my pants that seems a little too
that's what the dogs do i'm like
they just can't help themselves they
love us so much do they both do this
they both pee in excitement happy pee
yeah it's it's definitely a dog thing i
don't well a wiener dog definitely yeah
i mean yeah because barbara's barber
gets
embarrassingly happy but she's never
happy peed she does not pee she's got
that under control and she doesn't have
her like
the sounds that she makes are
embarrassing and there's like crying
it's like it's very intense i will say
it was makes you feel good significantly
more intense for jessie when she got
back from her trip to north carolina
than it was for me even though barbara
loves me to death
but she didn't give me
she didn't roll out the red carpet
in the same way that she did for jessie
and so i'm kind of holding that against
her oh yeah but she did not i mean she
will urinate on the carpet but it's not
but not because she's happy because
somebody didn't let her out when she
rang the bell so there's i'll start with
some bookends to this trip um
because
i botched the bookends
okay
um
first thing was we well i decided
strategically every other time we've
gone home we've just moved from house to
house and visiting with people and
celebrating
usually either thanksgiving or christmas
and you're moving around a lot a lot of
couch surfing and it's
um it's absolutely exhausting and
there's never any personal space
so especially with with three weeks
in this in this plan i was like okay
we're gonna try something new
um we're gonna stay at an airbnb also
christy's sister had just had a baby and
you know there was like the covid
protocols of it all and like maybe being
isolated and stuff like that and
and taking into account other people's
preferences in the family and well
basically just having a newborn in their
house meant that we could not
we couldn't stay at their house anyways
like a genius plan can i just say that
running an airbnb i've never done this
but i feel like this is a smart move i
mean we did the airbnb in the mountains
but yeah it was different
i feel like more people if you can
afford it yeah it can be you should do
this but i gotta say i think that many
families
would be
insulted by you deciding to stay
somewhere else and i think that people
just need to like just relax and just
don't i'm not saying this that would
happen but this happened in my family
i'm not saying this but i think that
there's for most people there's a
reservation to make the choice to do
what you did to stay at an airbnb
especially when you got to visit
multiple people oh gosh even if you're
gonna go and they have room and it's
just one family i think that having your
own space i think it only contributes to
the time together being sweeter
than having to just be up in each
other's space i think the quarantine
experience also informed this that okay
we're all in the same house so much more
that we learn to respect people's
boundaries and and be grateful that we
have a house where everybody can have
their own private space and re to
retreat into
so
having a renewed sense of that
importance
that also informed the trip now that so
that was not
botched that was that was brilliant
planning
so on the but on the back bookend
one of the things that you should do if
you're booking an airbnb
is
book it
for the entire
trip like don't book it for three weeks
minus one day
so we we
jenna's like putting her head down
it's not jenna's fault you didn't do
this i did this link did it and get into
my own hands i don't know what happened
but we're flying out numbers dates are
numbered flying out on the 23rd but we
but i put the checkout on the 22nd did
not know this never occurred to me until
um
noon on the 22nd you know the oldest
kids were you know they're still asleep
they sleep till noon right this is one
of those days where we weren't getting
up and visiting family and all of a
sudden there's like this aggressive
knock on the door and it's the it's the
cleaning lady coming to clean the airbnb
and um i opened the door and she's like
i'm
i'm here to clean and i'm like
well we're booked through tomorrow yeah
and she's like you definitely took the
wrong posture in this situation for some
reason i was so confident which was just
stupid i should have immediately known
that this was my fault right yeah but it
took me a second and she was like
yeah and then i pulled up the thing and
i was like oh crap you're right we'll be
out of here as soon as we can so then
i'm like waking up the older kids but at
least you were not in cancun and
you know i made the same mistake right
honeymoon right
i was in my bathing suit with
the sculpture in hand when this happened
to me but i had to stay at the a seedy
hotel in the you got a sculpture in your
hand yeah i just done the sculpture
class
and i was like holding a sculpture and
finding out that i was you know to be on
a plane oh yeah thank god we didn't it
thank god it wasn't the other so what
did you do where did you sing the street
well we i was like we can't extend
another day because she's coming to
clean for the next people to come in and
they're already asking then they can
they check in early and of course that
ain't happening so
we had stuff packed up enough because we
we had taken a mini trip okay there were
a couple of mini trips in there where we
had to pack everything up and visit
relatives a little further away which
i'll tell you about
um so fortunately
in record time
in about 20 minutes wow from
understanding that we did not belong
there anymore
we were out of there
and then i
i found another airbnb closer to the
airport for the final night
but it did make our last day pretty
our last our next last day pretty hectic
because in the last day was just getting
up and getting ready to go to the
airport and everything that was the back
end but right when we get there to the
air b i'm airbnb i'm feeling good i'm
like this is a good decision we have a
home base uh it's gonna revolutionize
this entire experience are you saying
things like that as a the dads tend to
do that they tend to say what you just
said to me you say to the family this is
good you have a home base and no one
cares yeah yeah you're you're doing it
for no one yes thank you yeah so don't
do them so next time just keep it inside
well
you know we have to learn to we have to
learn to inhibit that dad instinct
because
it's only going to get worse as we get
older they don't i've just noticed every
time i start trying to yeah talk about
how good the plan that i made is
everybody starts walking away slowly
yeah they don't miss a beat when i'm
they don't it's as if i'm just muttering
to myself
uh but emoting a little too much yeah
that's a good plan we got it we got a
home base
who's dad talking to himself and i'm
like okay well you know in order to
fully realize this experience i'm gonna
go to my room with my suitcase and i'm
gonna unpack all of my stuff like
elevate your suitcase on one of those
things did they have one of those no i
just put it on the bed i also elevated
christie's because hers was heavy and i
don't want any early vacation
suitcase lifting injuries
yeah you know i'm like i'm thinking of
all the potential pitfalls and i'm
putting everything away making this
space my own you know this is the launch
pad using drawers
i don't use drawers because
if you use drawers
you might you'll get you leave stuff in
drawers
unless you unless a drawer check is part
of the routine but i but i put out my my
my my toiletries in the right place and
i put my
uh my suitcase in
organize it in a way that it becomes a
drawer a series of drawers almost
as i'm doing that and and putting things
in my suitcase in like an open-faced
suitcase sandwich
situation
i realize
that i've overlooked a key
aspect of my uh apparel
i have not packed
any t-shirts
i didn't
i don't know you're gonna say like
because my dad didn't bring underwear
on the on the trip to the mountains
uh and so he had to like go to walmart
and get more underwear what is it easy
to correct what's the one category if
you were to miss it entirely would have
the greatest impact for me i mean i know
you're a tall guy
pants probably but during the during the
summer season shorts is not i mean
shorts don't it's not as big of a deal i
had a couple of shirts is about as bad
as it gets i brought a couple of
button-up shirts i knew we weren't going
to go out to dinner
that wasn't part of any of our plans
really
it was more of like visiting people and
t-shirts the only t-shirt i brought was
the one that i was sleeping in and the
one i was going to sleep in when the one
i was sleeping in was being washed
what's your packing system how did you
forget t-shirts i just i saved the most
important thing to last because in my
mind the t-shirts are the most important
part and i need to like make a big stack
of those well i know you got and i use
them to pad other things you got a lot
of assistance for things and i don't
have a lot of systems but can i just
give you my
i think the reason i don't forget
clothing on a trip now i'll forget other
things toiletries medicine whatever but
i don't forget
uh apparel yeah because i have the
toe to head check you sit yeah yeah so
i'm just like do you have all the shoes
that you want and the flip-flops yeah
everything that can go on your feet you
don't have to walk through it i
understand you
and then you get a good idea
but you get to the top and give me a
body scan but you get to the top body
scan and t-shirts are part of the body
this is the way that i do it i do it by
i have my drawers
organized by you know i got a socket
underwear drawer and then i've got um
i've got a
pants drawer and then i've got a workout
shorts drawer and then i've got some
miscellaneous drawer and then i've got
my shirts over here and my button ups
hanging over here so if i go to every
segment and take out the appropriate
amount of things from each place
then i've i've done it so what happened
i don't know i think but
returning to go to my t-shirt pile i
just
i just overlooked it entirely i don't
know what happened man you must somebody
who distracted you in the midst of it
i mean i ended up getting a text i ended
up finding
a shop and just buying a bunch of shirts
in one place i bought like
seven shirts like cool t-shirts or just
like an urban outfitters
i can still i can still get a t-shirt
from urban outfitters but not like you
didn't do like i'm gonna do the fruit of
the loom eight pack no okay there's
increasing number of things that i can't
buy in urban outfitters but t-shirts
there's i can still find some stuff that
that i don't feel like i'm posing i'm
not buying a bucket hat
and some some big old britches
like my son is
um so it it started and it ended
in in in shaky ways but there was
definitely some some highlights to this
thing i'll stick with the
airbnb um
lando came up to me on the first night
and he says
you know dad
together
is a beautiful place to be
and i felt
i just it just warned my heart i'm like
you thought he had like come up with so
sweet but i could tell by the look on
his face that he was doing some sort of
bit
and then i look over his shoulder
and there is a picture here that took a
picture of it no it's one of those
airbnb there's a decor
decision that's being made there's a
picture that says it it's it's just a
brown frame with a green mat and then a
white
uh
page that just has lettering on it
there's it's just words there's no other
decoration and the words say together
is a beautiful place to be that is
that is the piece of decoration i
understand the sentiment this would have
upset me because i'm i'm a i'm very anti
words on the wall in the house well very
i don't like messages i don't like
messages hung on the wall lando thought
i hate him was hilarious i think it's
ridiculous and it but it can go to
extremes it turns out
the only type of decoration in this
airbnb
motivational text based
pictures that lando had covered them all
up he had committed them all to memory
and he just and then he just start
spouting them off to me because he found
it very funny too
i think it's it's just
i i'm not going to say it's a southerner
it's a southern thing but
it's a southern thing and a midwestern
thing we were
you know
we're driving through all these like new
neighborhoods that they're building that
we're talking about last week and i
passed one neighborhood and it had a
they had a front porch it was one of
those new cookie cutter houses like oh
they're you know we're
we're up to date everything's
everything's brand new
on their porch they had a vertical
sign that was probably four and a half
feet tall
and a foot and a half wide and in
vertical letters on their front porch
the sign said
not welcome i've seen those two it said
porch
i swear to you they had a sign on their
porch that just said porch and it was
that big propped up next to their door
in an intentionally decorative way why
have art when you can have font
so right so lando i i mean i guess when
you're um
when you're
this was you know this is a full-time
airbnb it was well designed except for
the worst and renovated but this was a
choice that that that i question
these signs were everywhere
and let's see if you can finish some of
these sentences okay okay
here's another one in in the hallway
life isn't about finding yourself
life is about blanking yourself
touching
yeah now that might change your tune
right it's like wow this this house
really has something to say being life
isn't about finding yourself life is
about creating yourself give me a break
creating i like being yourself but
that's it's not assertive enough for an
airbnb wall
right next to it because this is a group
of three like a group of three
don't don't look at it oh gosh what were
these people thinking
life is better when you're
blanking
fishing
it's not a it's not
a tackle box themed house
loving i'm shabby chic i think is maybe
the word but
ing
life is better when you're eating when
you're loving that's good when you're
eating
yeah that's your mantra touching
yourself and eating
at the same
saying time lot about you i've done it
uh no this one is life is better when
you're laughing okay all right i mean we
got to agree with that right yeah but
the business but do you but life is
better when you're eating i don't know
what it is i'm not i'm not a natural
rebel but i just don't to me the reason
i don't like words on things is i don't
like people thinking things for me like
telling me like
it feels like i'm being prescribed a
bunch of things the way i'm supposed to
think about life and be i'm supposed to
be reminded that i'm special and i i
don't i don't want that if it's it's i
feel insulted by it i guess that's my
problem with it if you have a problem
with that then you wouldn't like the
wi-fi network name which was
uh
jesuslink one
and i don't know if they made it that
because they knew you were they were it
was like a
for me
i think it was just like link in like
the internet was the armani does that
mean the only way to connect with jesus
there is through the wi-fi
he only responds to wi-fi in this house
prayer doesn't work i did connect i'm
okay
all right i'm not done right
even with this trio in the hallway in a
world where you can be anything be
yourself
that's a little lazy
happy
but it is going to be that sappy joyful
in a world where you can be anything be
kind that makes me want to be unkind see
that's my problem you tell me to be kind
i'm like who came up with that
give me their address it's just i'm
going to aggressively knock on their
door it is heavy-handed i i didn't it's
it's lazy decor and it's and especially
to do it everywhere it's tacky that's
the big thing is i believe it come on
now i believe it is anybody ever in the
world like would you go into the louvre
museum and they're like this is the
section where people have written
motivational words onto things no
because nobody gives a damn about that
because it's lazy and it doesn't take
any
it just doesn't it's not expressive it's
prescriptive
if i want advice i'll ask somebody come
on now i i just feel preached too and
yeah even without the jesus link one
thing even i feel preached to everywhere
i turn in this house
i didn't write this in the review by the
way maybe i should identimize it well a
lot of people like it i'm not done
they're very popular here's another one
collect beautiful
memories close moments
and and then they had um
a coffee
coffee set and guess what
the coffee mugs
which is pretty nice hefty pottery this
is a different category for me every
single one of them had words written on
them like this is this is different to
me espresso this is okay
this is this is a mug mugs can have
things written on them because mugs are
not but pieces of art first and foremost
well it's this one's surrounded by decor
they're things that you use but it's an
exposed shelf and they were all facing
you so when you walk in the kitchen you
read them as if they were signage so it
is decor because it's constantly out
i guess it would be expresso yourself
what about
stay positive no i hate that stay
positive yeah i don't i don't i don't
need a message like that if there's a
pun i like espresso yourself that's
pretty good what about
keep it simple okay stop giving me
advice on the damn mugs i know
last but not least i like you a latte
that's good okay i mean i don't know
coffee related right yeah
i there were three or four more but i
got too exhausted to keep taking photos
but i i really i mean when your son
like ambushes you with a comedic bit
about it
it really it was a it was a milestone
moment in the in the vacation i was
really proud of lando to go into comedy
mode and he like he found humor in it
and he memorized all of them and then he
he would just speak in the inspirational
language of the decor hey and listen if
i'm wrong about this i mean obviously
these are popular they sell them
everywhere cracker barrel especially
uh if
this is if i'm missing something if i
need more don't say i we we're we are a
united front if we need more words we're
against it in our lives on the wall
tweet at us
okay hashtag your biscuit just tell us
why we're wrong
now if it's the thing above the toilet
about if you sprinkle when you tinkle no
that's okay please be neat and wipe the
seat that's okay that's different to me
go to mythical.com and get this travel
mug i don't care if you're not traveling
you can travel from wherever you are to
wherever you need to get this and then
you can bring it back to where you were
with it and it won't spill
and then it'll open up and
you can drink out of it it says things
on it but again it's drinkware
yeah so that's okay that's a good
mythical morning there's also you know
one at mythical.com we should sell we
should sell in the mythical store a wall
art
font thing that says that says don't
think don't put text-based art on your
walls
it's a psa it's ironic it's ex i like
this idea but and it's that whole decor
of like it looks exactly the same but
when you get close you realize that
there's somebody who's making fun of the
whole thing and it's the only one in the
entire house put your boys in your hands
mythical.com
a couple other highlights
um from my trip i i'm still sticking
with the airbnb i i haven't even gotten
to my family yet
lincoln was was sick with a cold at the
beginning your family gave it to him
well and my family got it from another
family and he really didn't
work and
we all took um
covet tests when we got there and and we
were all negative we know for a fact he
didn't have it um but we we kept him at
home because he felt so bad and we
didn't want to give anybody that we were
seeing
a cold
um we gave him nyquil i think that had
something to do with this but
he he started talking about all the
crazy dreams he was having when he'd
wake up at like noon
and see us
um but
let's see he would stay up he would stay
up so late that's why he was sleeping
late
and just hanging out with his friends
but one time he
he
texted his friends
and he said
i've been in a car accident
and
they put me on a stretcher
and they threw me through
the window and i'm in this i'm in i'm in
bed now
and i don't know what's going on
and
he actually texted this to me he said he
sleep texted his friends because he that
was the dream was he was in a car
accident and then they put him on a
stretcher and they threw him through the
second story window
that's beside his bed and he landed in
the bed and he was so scared and
disoriented that he texted his friends
for help and so they're like receiving
the message
at like
what would be like he's got your jeans
uh and then they quickly realize as he's
describing how they
emt's threw him through a window that
like dude you're
you're still asleep they're like
they knew that this was a possibility i
didn't i mean no they didn't but it was
the way that he was texting it was
coherent but the message i would have so
outlander i would have assumed it was a
joke before i assumed that he was sleep
texting because i didn't know that sleep
texting i talked to him and they were
freaking out at first because the first
text is i've been in a car accident
that's big
and why would he text you know
the next day christy and i are
downstairs and um
it's like 11 a.m and christy says
lincoln just texted me and said that
there's something on his light
and i told him i'm not going up there
because i'm watching she's watching some
show that she was really into
and uh virgin river
christie and her virgin river wow it's
like i thought it was the second season
it's still a virgin apparently things
move slowly well it's a really drawing
that one is like a lazy river i guess
uh she's like so i'm not going up there
um
and she texts him this and he says you
have to there's something online
you have to come up here and get it like
a bug so i grab
a broom and a paper towel
and i go upstairs and when i get
upstairs i mean it's broad daylight it's
11 a.m i look at the lincoln standing
there
beside the bed
he's facing the other direction a little
bit but i didn't really notice that
because i'm looking at the light and i'm
like and i have the stuff to come to the
rescue and i'm like lincoln there is
nothing on the light
and i look at lincoln and he's he's not
awake
he had a he had a text conversation
with christy about
a hallucination
on that light this is this is
i said lincoln there's nothing on your
light son
go back to bed or actually get up it's
it's 11 00 a.m he went back to sleep for
an hour
he was still i'm not a i'm not a sleep
expert but it feels like it feels like
this is a step or two beyond sleep
walking and the sleep texting there's a
there's a level of focus i looked into
it a little bit that happened that makes
me is it just because he was sick i
think those were factors but um this is
something he's gonna have to like
manage is what i'm getting at i i mean
especially in a foreign environment
where if you you're a little disoriented
and so you don't know
he wasn't used to where he was and he
was sick and he was on
had some nyquil or whatever
i don't i don't think it's cause for
alarm like
my aunt my aunt tc we were telling my
family about this and my dad was like
well you know when she was growing up
she would sleepwalk and she'd sleep
right out the front door onto the street
so it can't get um that's what i'm
getting at yeah i gotta keep an eye on
him which we do so everybody take his
phone and everything's gonna be fine tie
him down sleep texting but yeah i mean
people are known to like
there is such a thing as sleep sexing
like you could have sex in your sleep
i've done that it's happened
according to the internet
a couple other highlights of my trip um
we saw my brand new niece
sylvie
sweet little baby like it's been so long
since i held a newborn that i was i was
a tad bit nervous right
and then there was a sign that was like
always remember when you're holding a
baby
remember the gravy well chris okay this
is going to be okay i told christy that
i was like you know i'm
i actually feel a little nervous holding
holding the baby because and this is
just between me and her and then so when
we walk in the door and we're all
holding seeing the baby for the first
time she's like link said he was nervous
holding the baby so he's gonna have to
sit down before we give her to him
listen i this is a good call
i was not
yeah i didn't fight it
uh holding a baby is exhausting
uh i guess when you're that anxious
about it so i do have footage of being
entirely conked out
on the couch next to a newborn baby
which is so cute
you know i want to give that gift
to all the all the youtube watchers of
your biscuits
um
sylvie and her older proud brother
nehemiah were hanging out with them
uh
definitely a highlight
seeing my dad you might we had to drive
and spend we spent two nights at my
dad's house down in north myrtle beach
where he is permanently
living that beach life
uh we had a blast down there the kids
couldn't get over how warm the ocean was
you're gonna love this ocean it's so
warm you're not gonna remember how how
hot it is
and
one highlight was the fact that
everybody was willing to get in the
ocean and stay in it you know out here
on this pacific ocean only the youngest
or wet suited get in there christy
wouldn't dream of getting in that ocean
and like just hanging out with the
family so like actually all five of us
were like in the ocean the waves were
pretty mild just enjoying ourselves and
my dad was out there it was like it's
one of those rare times when you're
doing something as a family that
everybody's really into it is your dad a
body surfer uh he didn't body surf but
he has yeah he seems like a body surfer
he could body surf so he was just a
waiter i think he was waiting we were
just kind of waiting
you know just kind of chilling out the
waves were a little too tame for that
i don't know if you remember the last
time i talked about seeing my dad at the
beach talking about his golf cart
but if you don't remember it
it's this
like
gratuitously
wrapped in
sunset
it's actually the color scheme of of the
travel mug in a lot of ways like it's uh
like if jimmy buffett
vomited his feelings on all over uh
a golf cart and then somebody wrote
beach life in this weird font no that's
a good type good text but on a golf cart
that's acceptable so you don't remember
this the a
in beach
was such a weird font that it look if
you squint your eyes just a little not a
lot it looks like an l so
on at least three different places on
his
super
like it looks like a four by four golf
cart like mulch life
yes it looks like it says belch life oh
belch like belch belch life yeah
wow which is even better it's kind of
cool yeah
so
belch life is still going strong you get
on belch life you put your chairs there
and then you drive just a couple of
short blocks that might be better than
beach life to the beach um so that was
definitely a highlight going to
christy's parents house
driving down to kinston we hadn't we
hadn't the last few times we've been
down there they would always come up and
visit us so we hadn't been back home so
that
to the point that
at 11 years old lando had never been
fishing
with with grandpa
so this was a first
and lando caught his first fish a bass
in a lake
uh yeah in a pond
we went to a couple of ponds lincoln
caught a nice bass lincoln
congratulations you already caught a
fish man yeah man but i think it was
when i was had my hand on the
rod i was showing you how to use it
definitely not true i caught i caught
some fish too going back we threw them
back but lando i was concerned about
lando's potential concern
with the fight you know because i you
know you were talking about how uh
adeline your niece is so into fishing
she could probably teach lando a thing
or two like i didn't know if he would
want to actually catch a fish
but he's reeling this fish in and he's
like scared and thrilled and but then he
refuses to touch it
refuses to but i did get some photos of
him like standing sheepishly behind the
fish
that grand grandpa was holding but catch
a fish with granddad you know yeah like
our like our game yeah i'm not gonna
play it right now but in real life
so that was another highlight did he was
he upset with because you know so when
we we fished at that trout pond and it
was you could not it was against the
rules
to not keep the fish because that's the
business they charge you you buy the
pound this is a farm of trout that you
walk away with okay
and uh
this is a private pond and they give you
a bucket to put the fish that you catch
in
so it's i mean listen growing up
all kinds of fishing all kinds of
pulling hooks out of fish all kinds of
gutting fish like my relationship to
you know
killing and gutting and eating a fish
was something that from a very early age
i was okay with
but i kind of removed from it at this
point and it was like yeah there was
like a bucket of the trout that we had
caught and it's just like i mean these
trout are not doing well in this bucket
and then they're going to be doing
really bad when they get fellate and we
take them home and eat them um
so yeah our kids don't have i mean
shepherd kind of like is kind of in his
biology to just immediately kind of
adjust to it and be like this is awesome
we're catching fish i was surprised at
how well lando did but he was concerned
about the hook and i mean i i mean i
feel it because
when i caught a couple of fish you know
there was no discussion but i was like
okay grandpa you're going to be the one
touching the fish i'll be honest i did
not even touch it it gets it honest i
mean he had grandpa had gloves on which
helps you i guess grip the fish and
protect yourself from hooking yourself
and i don't know what i'm doing you know
we were retelling that old story of like
when when i hooked lincoln in the back
of the head when he was like six years
old with grandpa you remember that story
yeah
so i mean that that that scared him
going to visit nana uh was great you
remember when
our studio was just a few blocks from
nana and papa's house and we she would
always want us to come there for lunch
and she would always make that meatloaf
oh yeah she insisted i was like we'll
just bring food we don't want you to you
know
last time i saw nana she didn't have a
walker you know now she's got a she's
got a walker
and
mentally she's sharp and so it's always
nice to like
converse with her and it's so it's not
yeah she's getting older and she's got a
walker but she's tenacious and she's
sharp so it was um
and the fact that i didn't want her to
have to cook but she insisted on it
and then she breaks out this like this
that thin fried cornbread
and i i almost forgot that existed you
know it's been so long since i've had
some of that good
fry bread and like my kids didn't know
what it was
so that's another highlight is just
it you know you get a sense now that
every time you go home when it's once or
twice a year with the oldest relatives
with and nana is now the
only remaining living uh how does she
know grandma oh god
that'd be almost 90. 89 i think yeah
she
you know it's like okay she's giving us
the gift of making
a signature meal and actually she made
and then we came in all the time and she
insisted on making beef roast another
signature meal and there's just sense
that like okay
i don't know how many more of these i
have in me if you're only able to come
once or twice a year
let's you know
let's make this special and it
definitely was
you know and it's so there's this
exercise of going home seeing
how the
everybody's aged a little bit more or
some in some cases a lot more
and just cherishing what we've got
you know knowing that nothing lasts
forever
so that was that was a really sweet time
and and i knew that it was kind of
setting up for when i visited my mom and
when i visited my aunt vicki
that that that's when it was gonna
there's there was potential for things
to get more heavy and for us to enter
that headspace
and
of like okay
all good things must end at some point
um of course you know it was
it was last july
like in in
2020 when my nanny passed away
and because of
because of the circumstances of covet
and because of
christie's personal health and things we
were dealing with at home
yeah all of the factors came together
but if even if you probably just
isolated kovid that would have been
enough to to prevent all of us or and
even me alone
going back for the funeral so
um
i knew that when i this would be the
first time of going back into nanny's
house
with since she's passed away
and i knew that not much had changed in
the house because vicki hasn't been
living well i yeah i'll get to
explaining that in a minute but i knew
that
okay this was potentially a really
emotional moment for me because i didn't
know how much how much would come up
that i hadn't experienced
because
you know there's a level of it just you
know
experiencing the loss of of nanny just
it didn't
i didn't know how how much i processed
it how real it had felt because we were
so isolated and separated
and none of the
traditional grief
practices
i was able to i was able to do like i
had to i kind of had to invent my own
and i think we talked about some of that
uh
last year either in the the year end
or as it was happening i honestly can't
remember i know we talked about it at
year end but
um the mitigating factor or the other
factor is yeah what you're saying it's
like now my aunt vicki
um
lived with nanny and took care of her
for like her entire end of life she was
able to stay at home when they brought
in they brought in hospice at home she
didn't have to go and stay at the
hospital and die at the hospital
she was able to
pass away at home and
a lot of that was due to the fact that
like her her her youngest sister
aunt vicki
who had lived with her for
over 50 years was there to take care of
her
it's kind of amazing that like
okay there's nine siblings nanny is the
oldest and then aunt vicki is the
youngest she's seven years older than my
mom
so when aunt vicki was 21
she moved in
with
nanny and papa and my mom
who was
uh i guess
and it so it was uh
that was there was an interesting
dynamic there that i never knew anything
about that's like okay they're you know
now my aunt's living in the house like
all i ever knew growing up from my
youngest age was visiting nanny and papa
in the house that
is still the house that i that i went
back to
like my entire life that was
nanny and her house that was they were
they were associated with each other
nanny didn't have a license
like if she drove anywhere
she rode with
papa until he passed away in 1998
um
and then after that it was just her and
vicki and vicki would drive her
everywhere they they worked at the same
shirt factory in lillington for like
um over like 30 years like inspecting
shirts and putting on buttons and then
coming home and
doing it again the next day when nanny
retired vicky that's when vicki became
the lunch lady at tri one of the lunch
ladies at triton high school
uh
so which you know i've got which knowing
vicky is like a the perfect move you
know i've got a
a long and and deep and loving
relationship with aunt vicki like i was
the closest thing she had to having
never you know
gotten married or had a partner or
dated much that i know of it's like but
she had a she had a grandson in me you
know so
we had it we had a special relationship
and as an only child
um
i was you know now it's
this the dynamic of me making sure that
aunt vicki is taken care of
and then the state comes along and says
and they ca they've been there's been
rumblings of this for years but they say
we're going to
you your house is next to the highway
we're expanding the highway and i saw
like my mom sent me the plans months ago
they're putting the highway basically
through
the house well because the house was
already very close to the existing road
yeah yeah so
nanny passed away then we hear that like
these planes are definitely moving
forward vicki is in mourning and taking
this the worst because she is the
absolute closest to nanny for
all
all of these years
and now
like the place that
harbors all of their shared experiences
is being taken away from her
so it's like an additional level of
sadness
and so
when i went home and
and we'd encourage vicki
to
move in with
another sister of hers that's nearby
aunt lynette
who
we also love and see pretty often but
her her husband had passed away
a few years ago
so now she's kind of got an empty house
and and room for vicki to go so it's
like okay this seems to be lining up
you're going to have to move out of the
house so you can go ahead and start
living with aunt lynette but the way
that she did it was she just moved like
a minimal amount of stuff and then vicky
would just like come a lot of times
she'd just come back to the house during
the day
to nanny's house and just kind of
be there
you know i think just like this
prolonged morning
that
you know letting go of the house is
would is a painful exercise associated
with maybe
you know letting go and coming to grips
with nanny being gone right
i knew all of this but that further
complicated what i was stepping into but
i think that
i had this image in my mind that i was
going to go into the house
and
and have some time where i could just
kind of process and maybe shed a tear
and just have a moment where i was
going down memory lane and just you know
having a having a
uh an exercise in mourning right
unfortunately it it
that opportunity never really presented
itself because there was a lot of work
to be done on that front i think that um
i walked into the house and
i asked i asked nanny and i mean not
nanny i asked vicky and lynette to meet
me a little bit later but when you tell
old people to meet you somewhere
they always show up like an hour or two
early yeah so they were already there
and and and
because i had set aside the entire
afternoon and i was like mom's going to
come over too
and i'm going to see what we're up
against here because we have to start
organizing and moving this stuff out
vicki you need to move everything out
that you need to live with lynette and
then whatever's what and then whatever
you want the special whatever mom wants
it special we got to start getting this
stuff out of the house so like
i kind of knew that i would have to step
in and provide the leadership to work
through this logistically because
as i'll talk about
next my mom's got so much on her plate
vicky's going through so much and unders
that i needed to
i needed to make this happen is there
like a date for when they're gonna like
level the house not not yet i mean
they're appraising it and they're
supposed to give us an offer and then
there'll be some sort of negotiation how
much they're going to purchase the house
and the land for and
so we're going to have to cross that
bridge soon but i wanted vicki to be in
a comfortable space at lynette's house
with all of her stuff and not prolong
this limbo
so i'm like
we're gonna put labels on things if you
want stuff we'll put a label on it and
you don't have to move anything yet but
then we'll know what's labeled as and
with who's wants it is going to get it
and then whatever's left
i'll i'll have to figure out how to get
rid of that stuff with like an estate
sale or something afterward i've never
done any of this stuff
but it's but it's i've quickly realized
i walk into the house and like okay
we're in go mode i got to try to figure
this out i got a limited amount of time
and i'm tr i'm trying to hurt these cats
that are my relatives a couple of other
relatives show up by the way because i
think once you start going through
people
labeling stuff once you start labeling p
everybody's got a label people gonna
come out of the woodwork to see what
they want and you know what it was
totally fine it was you know i think
with a lot of families this is where it
gets to be a nightmare situation yeah i
had helped nanny with her will
i i actually think that getting the will
in place was one of the things that was
like keeping her holding on for as long
as she did
she almost she basically articulated
that when i was talking to her you know
there was like six months leading up to
her her passing that we were getting all
that in place the last time she left the
house
was to go and get the will
straightened out so
because of that work that we had all
done
it made it it wasn't
it wasn't painful right and it wasn't
there wasn't conflict thank god
but still it was uh
just the task was so difficult that you
kind of had to keep your emotions that
they just wasn't room for that at that
point
um
and then i realized even after labeling
stuff i'm like okay
i've got to co i've got to find an
entire other day to come back and
actually box stuff up just for
aunt vicki to move out like i literally
have to move her out
so then i had
christie and i came back and
you know it actually turned out to be a
special time when we were like boxing up
all of her stuff and then getting movers
to come and actually move all of it and
going through her stuff something that
could have been very painful i think
because
it was kind of like i was i was able to
step in and
love her in that way
that it uh it made it
it it made it a positive experience you
know i felt like i was actually able to
help i mean we
you know there were times when she would
break down crying and
i would be there for and like we could
encourage her but when we were also
getting this job done like was a very
tangible way to say
we're we have to move on and we're we're
in this together and i'm here for you
i'm like she didn't feel like she was
being forced forced out well i mean and
if she was we can blame it on the state
yeah which is it was actually kind of
nice because i didn't i didn't want her
to live alone
um
so that was
that was
it wasn't
it wasn't as difficult as i thought and
i
because it just couldn't be
you know
uh it had to be what it was
i i so maybe there's still some
emotional work for me to do and i do
think we had our
our moments and mom and i had our
moments and
um
especially when you're going through and
like i found some keepsakes like when i
was a little kid some stuff that i toys
that i would play with like a few of
those things and like
my granddad's
um there was more stuff i found of him
that i didn't find when he passed away
like uh his
all of his deputy sheriff badges well
like he i mean
he had one that's a belt buckle i got a
sheriff again so you wrote a sheriff
buckle badge
and we're looking through old photos and
like i'm taking some pictures of
digital pictures of old photos because
i'm not they're not my albums but i want
like a version of it
but yeah i mean i definitely find myself
thinking
wow look at all these
really old photos of all these people i
will never know
and
i you know i don't know anything about
their lives i know that i'm distantly
related to these people but it
definitely there's like a depressing
angle to that it's like i i can't all of
these people i can't stand looking at
old pictures because it yeah it even all
pictures of my family
almost always end up with this like yeah
depressed feeling that that is in the
past and i can't access it and it's just
like life is moving too fast i felt some
of that and there was this you know
there's this one
photo of me in
nanny and vicki's kitchen
and
um
i was
i was probably one years old and i was
just
i was dressed like winnie the pooh
meaning i was only wearing a shirt no
okay like i was in a costume i i'm
looking in the bottom cabinet that's
like two feet off the ground and it's at
eye level and my ass cheeks are hanging
out and now i get i went in i was going
in that kitchen and we were boxing stuff
up and nothing had changed like
for all of those years
from the moment they built and decorated
their kitchen with the red countertops
and like strawberry wallpaper like
nothing ever changed except how big my
ass cheeks got right and you typically
wear pants when opening fridges now but
there was a sweetness to looking at
photos of of
mom and like i've i found the uh
like the
the bulletin of the brochure from when
my mom and dad got married like it had
their wedding vows in it and
like the the guest book i was like
looking through the guest book of like
because mom didn't keep that but
nanny kept it in the bottom of a
uh
a chest
and it was so it was surreal it's like
okay my i don't see anything of my
parents being together just maybe a
couple of pictures and here i am looking
at like the newspaper article their
announce engagement announcement and
their wedding day and looking at the
wedding
uh
order of service and
everybody who showed up and
but
i don't know it was it was the pictures
of people that i didn't know that
somehow in that moment felt more
poignant to me
like
these people are
long gone and i never
i never knew anything about them and
it's like what
you start to think things like what
difference does it make
you know it's like
there's a temptation to start thinking
that type of stuff you know so
there was a little bit of that but i'd
and it so they're
it's a little depressing to say okay
and some of this stuff is just going in
the trash
you know some of the stuff that you kept
for 50 years
these things on the wall like
uh
aunt vicki kept her shot glasses
she has all she never she doesn't drink
at all but she collects shot glasses
from everywhere that she visited we kept
all of those to move into
the net's house but
it's you know death is a part of life
and also we're at an age where we're
we're assuming the responsibilities of
of helping our
aging relatives move into their next
phase of life and
death
i mean and i i think that
that mindset definitely continued when i
went to moms
um
you know
you you know more about mom's situation
but i'm
i
i think it's a it's a good time to i'm
ready to share more about the context of
what mom's been dealing with just
because
um
we're we're processing it we're wrapping
our minds around it
um at the i think our year end
our 2020 year-end
uh podcast i alluded to the challenges
that my mom was facing and how i wanted
to be of support to her and
um
how that was a
a big a big factor
of course right you know
in 2019
in earlier 2019 mom
and louis visited and then that's when
the whole story of
uh louis
like going getting hospitalized and
almost dying
uh because of
bleeding in his
lower gi tract and
uh he was on the verge of death multiple
times and
we were
we were there
i mean i i
i outlined that that surreal experience
of him being on the brink of death
for the entire visit and and wondering
is he going to make it and and is he
even going to be able to go back home
but he got to a point in his recovery
where he was able to fly home and i
think where we left the story
at the time was he gets back home and
he's he's doing good enough like he's
grabbed his leaf blower and he's blowing
off his
is his car carport
and he's back in his own space and he's
good good good
you know it was the this
the sad thing that happened was it
within
within the next week or so he suffered
that's when he suffered a series of
strokes
and then was
hospitalized
and
um
if you
if you fast forward to july
that's when we went home
to film
us going back to bowie's creek to do
that like our our homecoming miniseries
where we like
associated with bleak creek where we
talked about like the inspiration for
the
for the novel and all that and i
remember
uh every day we would shoot all day we
went swimming in the river we went to
the we went to
all over bowie's creek
um
and then i remember every night the crew
would hang out and i would leave as soon
as we were done filming and i would
drive to the hospital to visit mom
who was carrying who was on at lewis's
bedside because
even those few months later after having
this the strokes
he was
he was
now
uh at points he was on a ventilator
and he was near death again like i was
visiting every night
that i was there
knowing that he could pass at any minute
so it was kind of like a repeat of the
whole thing
it was it was
really scary and really sad and he was
of course he was not conscious
for any of my visits
and um
i don't think my mom slept the entire
time it was she was just basically in
shambles but
and then
but it was nice to be there at such a
pivotal moment
um
then just to fast forward through
the entire next year and going through
covid and and everything basically it
was just a series of coming to grips
with the fact that
what is what is he
lewis's he got out of the hospital he
made it out he's he he made it home he
went through some therapy for
for his strokes and then
he eventually left uh
the therapy centers
and then came home and you'd have
therapists visiting and nurses visiting
and over the over the course of the last
i guess you know
two years year and a half or more
the the amount of external care has has
gone down as we've come to grips with
um
you know what his life is going to be
like from now on like his capacity i
don't know you know when you when we
visited him
in thanksgiving in 2019
he would he he wasn't doing well but he
was at home he was
he was extremely skinny it was like
oh shocking to see him
and he wasn't he wasn't very
communicative and his
his
it just felt like he was probably
10 of his former self
and
even since then
mom's and come to the come to grips with
how
he needs to be cared for and her being
the primary
uh caregiver for him and nurse for him
to to help him do basically everything
he does
um and
that's been a
and so if you
if you lay that experience over top of
my description at the at the end of
last year on the podcast
if you can remember my descriptions then
maybe it would
um
shed more light on the
the depth of the challenge that we were
facing and are facing so it was it was
it it's been extremely frustrating to
not physically be there with mom
and just to just to have to be there for
her over the phone
that was the dynamic that i i believe i
was describing at the time
so i knew that when we came home
there's only so much you can learn over
the phone right
so it's i felt like i would learn a lot
more being there and and being able to
spend and spend an extended amount of
time and observe
the challenges that mom faces and have
bring fresh perspective to how we i
could
uh suggest changes and
start to look into how she might get
more help
um
there's somebody that that comes in
basically
a sitter who who sits with louis and
makes sure he's good to go and okay so
mom can like run errands
a number of times a week
um
i i was encouraged when we went home
that like lewis had he'd gained his
weight back and
you know he i he was able to call the
kids by their names
which which was
very encouraging
and
he doesn't he only he only really speaks
when spoken to and he'll like answer he
can answer questions more yes or no are
you hungry do you
that type of thing
he's not a conversationalist anymore uh
he he doesn't he can't use
a phone anymore much less a computer
you know he
uh so it's it is it's it's really sad
um but it's also very poignant to
it was it was poignant to know it and
hear it from mom but then to see
the level of commitment and care that
she has for him that like
coming to grips with this is what their
life together is going to be like
from here on out
uh it's not it's not really going to get
better at this point we pretty much know
that
and if
we don't know exactly what this a slow
decline will look like
but
i drew i've drawn tremendous
levels of inspiration from my mom
first of all
always because of who she's been to me
and the sacrifices that she's always
made for me but like this takes it to a
new level the fact that she does
everything for him
uh you know
he can he can
he can feed himself
uh
and he can
get up out of bed and he can stand with
a walker but usually he's he's she's
moving him from a bed to a wheelchair
and
but
just being being willing to follow
through on her commitment to
uh take care of him you know to be there
uh
in sickness not only in health is
in her attitude associated with it i
mean
you know my mom's all she's the sweetest
person but at a certain point even this
even the sweet the people with the
sweetest hearts break and sometimes i
feel like they're at risk of
uh breaking
the most because they because their
hearts are so big you know so i think
that's been my fear for my mom is that
because she's such a big-hearted person
that there's more of a risk of of her
experiencing that much more pain and she
clearly is going through what i mean
an unimaginable level of pain where she
describes to me that it's like she says
link there are times when
i can still see i can see the old lewis
i can see it in his eyes like he comes
back to me it's almost like she's
describing someone who has alzheimer's
even though he doesn't it's just it
that dynamic guy is at play with
if if stroke impacts certain areas of
your brain
um
and i was like mama how often does that
happen and she's like well maybe maybe
once every
few weeks or a month i'll see that
glimpse you know and it's
she's able to take care of him at this
particular stage
um
but the fact that her heart just
as as broken as i i know it is the fact
that she's still able to
exercise
and live out
loving her husband is
is
i mean i've never seen i've never had
the privilege of seeing that so up close
uh
so i think
i knew it was going to be
difficult for that reason but it was but
it it's a it's a beautiful thing
uh
and um
i
i want to memorialize
this experience as a as actually a
positive experience
and
and i'm glad to be able to say okay
how can i help uh
we're still navigating through that but
and then figuring out practically what
if things need to change what those are
but you see how
i mean it's one thing to look at
pictures and have this exit existential
dialogue with yourself of
is this
does this even does this even matter
but i think there's
i think that's the
that's that
my experience in
in
in seeing my what my mom's going through
is kind of a is is the answer to that
question
for me and
but it also puts me in a headspace of
like
like i was saying with aunt vicki we
we're getting
to an age where
we're gonna we're gonna have to deal
with this with eventually with
our aging relatives our you know our
parents too and starting to think about
well what's that going to look like
but
um
you know you i mean
especially as an only child you know i i
feel like okay it's i mean it's gonna be
on me
christy has a sister
you got a brother i mean it doesn't
maybe in some ways it might it might
complicate things
but i don't i mean are you
do you think about that
i mean
it's it's still a little early to make
plans but then what's when you're
blindsided by what happens to louis
court anything can happen at any time
and
it's just
okay these are these are decisions that
we're going to have to run point on for
our families yeah well i mean i i think
about it quite a bit i
i would say over the past
um
few years
you know i would say that for me part of
it was
uh
you know my parents haven't dealt with
significant
debilitating health problems
um
but like even something as
um
small it wasn't small ended up being a
big freaking deal for her but like her
breaking her ankle when we were in
scotland yeah and then like and being
there during that time but then i wasn't
there during her recovery you know i was
talking to her staying in touch and i
was talking to my dad
and like he was transitioning into
retiring which actually
literally like two weeks or so before we
got to north carolina he had taken his
keys to to campbell oh really to the law
school for the last time because he was
doing some sort of like
part-time stuff so he's literally like
fully transitioned into retirement
and you know they
you you look at your parents and you're
like man
they're old you know what i'm saying
like you yeah they the way that you
perceive them
in the way that they
sort of present themselves physically
the way that they talk
you begin to be like oh i have elderly
parents
you know what i'm saying i mean it's
interesting because my i had a
conversation
uh
with my my dad about this aspect of
how you perceive
yourself getting old uh-huh and he was
like you know because my dad is a tough
son of a [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying he always has
been
and will do anything physically that you
ask him to do you know he's so he's 75
years old
but like
when he was here a couple years ago like
he walked all the way down the hill from
my house to the yeah
this isn't something that typical people
of that age do yeah and like we play
golf together he was gonna go whitewater
rafting with us
but he didn't because his back was a
little bit messed up from the from the
from from golfing because we must
mclaughlin's really know how to swing it
uh but he was talking about the
he's like i still see myself as an 18
year old kid i think that's important
you know and until you do something
stupid right well but the thing is is
that but we were talking about that in
in relation to my mom's health which is
which is which is fine
but you know she has a she has a little
bit of a different attitude i mean for
the past
ten christmases or so
uh
she she'll throw out of this could be my
last christmas i'm like mom it could be
anybody's last christmas
you know we all could die
but yeah it's there's this um
i think it's a running joke with her
yeah when i just talked to my dad this
morning he just had he he just got back
from the hospital had surgery for the
first time in his life
mclaughlins hate hospitals
and we don't like getting sick so we
don't get sick if we can't help it right
okay we don't like getting hurt so we
don't get hurt if we can't help it but
he's he's been he's had he this is i'm
sure we're gonna i'm gonna be doing a
podcast on this at some point
he's had kidney stones and so is my
brother and they're like it's only a
matter of time
so they're like i can't they're like
they just can't wait till it happens to
me because it's been so painful for them
but he went and got the surgery where
there were so many kidney stones and one
kidney that they basically
opened him up and took them all out of
one of his kidneys and it just happened
yesterday and so then he just came home
from the hospital they left a few days
ago
yeah they gave them to you in a little
bean bag and you play cornhole with it
so that's nothing no i guess uh no i
don't well yeah i don't know you could
probably get him uh but
you know i was just talking to him about
being in the hospital and he was and he
was like he's like you know
it's no fun
and he's like this and he says i'm not
going to do this again
he said this is hard when you're 75
years old
you know so i think that there's been a
number of things in the past
few years that you begin it begins to
register that you're like okay
these people are not going to be around
forever and when you get to that stage
in life
sometimes things happen like what
happened with louis that suddenly
your your existence and the
relationships that you have with
everybody else changes dramatically like
your mom's lifestyle has changed
dramatically yeah you know my parents
haven't experienced that
um and then i start to think like
well it's you know
if
if mom outlives lewis and then it's like
well is she gonna come out to california
and live with me and like
we're not have i mean we have so much
other stuff to talk about it's not like
we're making those plans we're not
talking we we're we haven't had a
discussion at all about that but just i
start to think about things like that
it's like well uh
you know and but for older relatives
like i know for your mama nell she was
in a she was in a nursing home that like
you know your parents could visit and
like you i even visited mama now a
couple of times
like uh she seemed all right in there
but she she liked to uh she liked
to watch television okay she always but
she
she basically in the retirement home
she was doing exactly the same thing
that i had only ever seen her do
except
sands the whiskey and cigarettes she
could she didn't have whiskey in there i
don't think so no smuggled you had to go
outside to smoke yeah but in her house
she would sit in her chair and smoke
cigarettes and drink whiskey and watch
television in the retirement home she
would just watch television
so it probably wasn't as fun
uh but yeah yeah and and
you know that was a long time ago and i
don't you know i i don't remember it
well i remember
i do because my dad's also an only child
right so
uh
i remember thinking like oh my dad has
like
he's had to like do this he's had to
like take responsibility for his mom
because there was nobody else to do it
you know she never lived at your house
for any period of time did you know the
play it was like it was literally like
you know it was a place in willington
like halfway down the road from it was
like three minutes away i know you're
your dad jokes about coming and living
with you in sunny california if he
outlives
mama die
yeah and
he's probably he's only half joking
um
but
yeah i mean the thing i've been thinking
about mostly with them at this point
is
especially for my dad because he's the
one who's kind of transitioning from
like having this
daily routine of like being a professor
and now he's like retired and he's like
he's like i mean
because when we were on when we were in
the mountains together and i was like
all right we got to
we got to get up it we need to be on the
road at like eight o'clock and we said i
gotta i guess i gotta get up early
he's like i've been getting up at nine
o'clock since i retired so he's enjoying
it he's like and he gets up and he's
like i take my time i go on a walk
you know so he's beginning to sort of
figure out what his life is going to be
um and i think it's only a matter of
time before he gets a little stir crazy
and has to has to do something
and it's always better if you are going
to do something i mean that's the thing
i'm encouraging i i when we visited my
dad i was watching him closely
because we're so much alike like
physically like the way that our bodies
are built and like
you know it's
uh well first of all
like i don't know if anybody knows that
my dad has
a form of leukemia
like he was diagnosed in 20 it was 2019
i believe he was diagnosed it was uh
lymphocytic
leukemia he didn't have he turns out he
only has to take a pill
and then he got and he got his blood
count straightened out and now he's been
going in for checkups every six months
and like he's actually
doing great and it's it's a it's
it's very treatable it can be managed
with just a pill like he never did
had to do like
chemo or radiation or i i don't even
know the ins and outs of the specifics
of treating right uh
what you typ the typical leukemia but
this it's a little different and he's
taking a pill
and
but um
so he's doing great he's still i mean he
still works he still like works on
houses he like moved his entire business
down to the beach but he does it on his
own terms and he doesn't have a crew
anymore but he's active and he's but
he's not
and i i that he enjoys it i think it's
that level of engagement i don't think
he would
even though he's golfing more and he's
you know he's on the beach a lot and of
course their main thing is it's still
shagging the night away yep that is a
dance to dance for those of you i'm from
england but i'm like watching him
closely and like what is he what is he
able to do and i was like dad you gotta
i notice you got a limp and i'm like oh
crap am i gonna get a limp
and he was like
i got i was working on something and
like a
a screw got
caught in my thigh
or something like that it was like a
barb or something and then he's like
then we went on a trip to the mountains
and i got swole up and i got infected
and i ended up having to go to the
doctor and
um
it sounded like one of those things
where if you didn't get the infection
it could have been bad and he was just
getting over that so trutha other than
that
which he's basically almost recovered
from like he typically doesn't have a
limp and i'm like okay that's that's
good the limp is not normal at his age
he's still
and he's still able to
walk to the pizza shop when the kids at
like he made he made his signature ribs
then we made homemade peach ice cream we
each ate two bowls of this ice cream
we're like completely stuffed and then
uh lily says
you know what i could
go for right now or like a bed
it's like nine o'clock at night ten
o'clock at night and um
she's like pizza
and i i laughed at her and like i just
thought she said it was saying it maybe
she was kind of serious but she she was
just saying it as a joke and the dad was
like well we can walk two blocks that
way and there's a pizza shop and then
lily's like do they sell it by the slice
he's like of course they sell it by the
slice if you let me take a shower we'll
all walk over there jack yeah and lily
and lincoln looked at each other like is
he serious it's like okay yeah we're
gonna we're gonna we're gonna walk we're
gonna walk a couple of miles here at
like 11 30 at night by the time
everything
shakes down at home and he takes a
shower and then so like we're going out
there and we're getting pizza and he's
like he's moving and shaking now this is
a now and this is something that if
you're going to become more like your
dad as you get older i think that you
know that's not a that quality of 11 30
pizza is not something i associate with
link neal that i know right that's
coming from somewhere else but you've
got those jeans those genes to be
flexible enough to first of all be
willing to go but like i i i've eaten
with your dad before i get the
impression that he's a bigger eater than
you
he he's not a i'm a one-plate man and
i'm done uh
he's he's actually slowed his roll a
little bit because i like dad if you
lost the weight he's like i'm just you
know i'm keeping it
i'm keeping it slim
by the way he did make it out of the
pixelated woods
uh this this story there was that they
were like traveling and he kept wanting
to set up these like they were in these
like beautiful places and for the 2000
episode greeting from him i think he
thought
this is a beautiful spot here in the
woods let's like let's use the flip
phone and get a video of it
he had a lot of trouble getting that
thing sent so
so it was no longer the file was
degraded in transfer it wasn't the phone
yeah
he had to seriously compress that thing
he said he said i shot three different
videos for y'all
and that was the best one
i love it i wouldn't want it to happen
and you know what he's
i'm encouraged like okay so you know
what i can probably i can probably do
even better than him like i can give
more attention to my posture and to my
workouts well and you know he and he he
made the decision
he made the decision to move to myrtle
beach right
because he wanted to did he wanted to
dance it it wasn't the pizza shop was
next to three different dates it wasn't
like places man i got to go to myrtle
beach for this job
right it was like you know what
i can move to myrtle beach like that is
a thing that i could choose to do
and his wife is the kind of person
that's just like okay let's do it well
no she's like i want this too
guess who bought you know how dad
remember he had that like
convertible banana yellow corvette yeah
even if you don't remember you can i
remember big picture and he sold that
years ago guess who has one now nancy's
got a nancy yellow corvette nancy bought
one like a new one
uh because the new corvettes
like no uh it's an old one they almost
look like ferraris it's an it's it's and
i don't know anything about sports cars
but i saw a new quarter like a circa 90s
they don't look the same anymore uh hers
is red
but yeah it's like they are peas in a
pod i'm so happy for them find somebody
who likes corvettes and mood of myrtle
beach if that's your thing but one day
i'm gonna have to figure out what's your
murder what kind of what's your corvette
but before that i'm gonna figure out how
how how does my dad need to be cared for
you know it's like
nana nana's gonna need to know how to be
cared for and
uh i'm gonna observe what
aunt tc and and dad decide there and how
that how that plays out
but it's like
okay i gotta see one of these days i'm
gonna have to make sure that he's taken
care of you know and it's
it's like man we're really that old that
we got to start figuring that stuff out
yep
but i mean we plenty of people have done
it before us
it's just you find the right people to
talk to and
i think we can figure it out but it's
it's sobering it was so and just in
summary i think this was a
it was a sobering trip it was a it was
um
you know when it when an ambassador
visits somewhere it's called what it's
called a something trip whatever that's
called it felt like that it felt like i
was a
um
you know i had a few missions that i
needed to accomplish in addition to just
loving and being loved on
but um i mean that was the part of it
that that that made it all worthwhile
was the fact that we do love each other
and
uh warts and all
aging and all challenges and all and
um so it was it was difficult i wouldn't
call it a vacation i would call it more
of a
more of a reconnaissance mission
but
using that criteria it it was a success
and i was i'm i'm grateful to do it and
i think coming back home
the things that really made it feel
worthwhile was when
they're like we would make inside jokes
about
family members
the kids the kids would be making inside
jokes about their grandparents and their
great grandma and
the food that we ate and the funny
things that grandpa says because he
intentionally mispronounces way too many
words
and it becomes a part of our
conversation back home it's like okay
the kids have reconnected with their
relatives and it means something to them
and so one day when they're looking at
photos of of relatives long past it
won't be like who are these people and
does it even matter
instead they'd be like i know those
people and maybe i only got to see them
a couple of times a year but
i love them and they enriched my life
and uh
it was it was
it was an
it was an honor to know these older
people who i'm related to you know and i
i miss not giving them that gift on a
on a weekly basis by living in the same
county or the same state but it it was a
good reminder that
um
those connections could still be special
and they can be
meaningful long term
well thanks for telling us about it
um
i'm going to recommend something that i
talked about last week that i think is
just fitting with what we've talked
about
today do it uh you know i talked about
those four different
documentaries or specials to watch but
the
the one documentary some kind of some
kind of heaven
uh you didn't say that one last week it
did some kind of heaven yeah i can't
remember it in and of itself but you
didn't say i said inside in and of
itself some kind of heaven and then uh
tell me who i am oh okay some kind of
heaven again is a documentary sort of in
an errol morris oh kind of fashion oh
that's the retirement home and it's the
village's retirement community in
florida which is the largest retirement
community it's a small s it's a large
city over 100 like 50 000 people live
there maybe that's where i'm gonna send
all my relatives well first of all so we
you know we watched it with my
brother and sister-in-law and then lance
and lacy and then
after that on the group chat that we had
for
that group
for the vacation group
uh lance or lacey sends a text to the
thread and is like
you know you can actually go spend a
week
or spend as much time as you want really
as like a trial package at the villages
for it's like it's like 150 bucks a
night or something like that and you go
and it's the people who want to go
vacation there to see if this is where
they want to go and we were talking
about all going on a vacation to the
villages
like now as you know mid-40s year olds
but i thought i thought okay
but i thought you'd watch the
documentary and wouldn't want to visit
no so
i mean there's a little bit of both
it is a it's a great
film because it is a very honest look at
the people and
what it's like to be at that stage in
your life you know there's there's loss
and there's love
and
uh i think that for some people it's it
feels like it's an incredible choice and
just the things that like you know
things that were like kind of obvious to
be like oh yeah like when these are the
kinds of things that happen in a
retirement community now a retirement
home is a very difficult a different
thing like yeah where mama nell was
versus the retirement community which is
like these people are constantly doing
all kinds of [ __ ]
you know and it's just such a really
well done film that
it'll make you think about yourself
getting older and what you want your
life to be like and how you want your
life to end
you know what i'm saying like if you
want to end well
well since i'm in the headspace i might
as well go all the way and watch this
film uh so i i recommend it some kind of
heaven i'm
98 sure that's the the name of it and i
can't remember which one of the
streaming services it's on but i'm sure
you can get it
um
just google it and figure out
all right
belch life i mean ear biscuits let us
know
what you think and we'll talk at you
next week
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]